My opponent tonight is
Democratic congressman,
Ted Lieu--
here's what you need to know.
He represents the state
of California in congress.
Meanwhile, California represents
the state of moral decay
in our country.
He's a member
of the Democratic Caucus,
where he serves
as an assistant whip.
I'll ask him
for Adam Schiff's safeword.
-(laughter, groans)
-He's a colonel
in the U.S. Air Force Reserve,
but he won't trick me with
any sexy volleyball montages.
Congressman Ted Lieu, everybody.
-Congressman.
-(cheering, applause)
Thank you.
Congressman, just want to get
a little small talk
out of the way.
No big deal, but who did you
vote for in the last election?
-I voted for myself.
-You d...?
Yeah. Who did you vote for?
I'm not gonna answer
that question.
I find that inappropriate.
You have given our president
a pretty hard time.
Have you given him
a fair chance?
I have. I didn't set out
to run for congress
to resist the president.
I served active duty
in the Air Force.
I believe America
is an amazing country.
So after last November's
elections,
I actually wrote a memo
that said:
Hey, Donald Trump won
the electoral college.
One of the great things
about America
is our peaceful transfer
of power.
We should give him
a chance to govern.
About two months later,
I concluded I was wrong.
(laughter)
Did you... did you
release that memo?
I made it public.
-You made the memo public?
-I absolutely did. I did. Yes.
And I read the underlying
information as well.
-You did your research?
-I did.
(whooping, applause)
That's your first mistake.
You're on the House
Judiciary Committee.
Have you read the memo?
-I have not, but it doesn't mean
I can't talk about it. -Great.
For the same reason
that Chairman Nunes
wrote the memo without reading
the underlying information.
Well, it's not about what
you know or what you've read,
it's about, like,
what you understand
and who you want to convince.
There's only three things you
need to know about this memo.
-Great. -First of all, Democrats
have a better super secret memo
than Republicans.
-(laughter)
-Second...
It's a follow-up, it's a sequel,
nobody likes the sequels.
Do you think anybody liked
Godfather II?
So second,
their hyper-partisan GOP memo
was written based on the
chairman not actually reading
the underlying information.
And third,
there are two organizations
that have read
the underlying information:
the Senate Intel Committee
and the Department of Justice,
and Chairman Nunes
won't give them the memo,
because he's scared they're
gonna tell him he's wrong.
Why are you so scared
of this memo?
Are you in this memo?
I'm not scared of this memo.
I just think the Democrats
have a better one.
Do you think
it's gonna come out?
Um, it doesn't really matter,
'cause it's a stupid memo.
(laughter)
(whooping, applause)
Again, the Democrats have
a better super secret memo.
Oh, the Democrats have
a better plan,
a better way to deal
with health, right?
-We do have a better deal.
-You didn't have a better path
to the White House,
I'll tell you that much.
You are also pretty critical
of Jared Kushner.
Absolutely.
And you've been pushing to take
away his security clearance,
or showing that he doesn't have
security clearance.
So this is what we know about
Jared Kushner...
That he's the son-in-law
of the president
and should get what the hell
he wants.
Well, that apparently is
what's happening.
So to get a security clearance,
you have to fill out
what's known as an SF-86
security clearance form.
I had to fill those out to get
my security clearance.
They're very intrusive,
and they say
if you lie on it,
you'll be prosecuted.
Jared Kushner lied twice on two
of his security clearance forms.
He had to submit three
to get it right.
In addition,
he's under investigation
by special counsel Mueller's
office.
No one in that kind of situation
should have
a security clearance.
Sounds like he's got
a lot of eyes on him,
so he's probably fine.
Well, so that's a good point.
He is now in a compromised
situation, right.
So foreign powers know they can
leak things,
whether it's true or not,
and put him into even
deeper trouble.
That's why his
security clearance
needs to be revoked immediately.
So what-what do you want to do
about this?
As somebody who's in
a position of power,
what can you do about
something like that?
Help me take back the House
and we'll revoke
his security clearance.
(cheering, whooping, applause)
You are on your own here,
let me tell you.
Do you have a plan?
How are the Democrats gonna
take back the House?
Give me your plan and maybe I'll
help you,
and by that I mean thwart you,
but listen to the first part.
We have a better deal
on the economy.
This GOP tax scam was really
a bad deal for the
middle-class families.
83% of all the benefits are
eventually gonna go
to the top one percent
of America.
Many middle-class families are
going to end up getting
the short end of the stick.
And when you look at all
the activism out there,
these amazing women's marches,
you see huge amounts
of voter behavior shift,
and we just flipped a rural
state senate seat in Wisconsin.
All the activism and energy is
on the part of the Democrats.
Now, the doomsday clock
just clicked
one more click closer
to midnight.
Yee-haw, I guess?
You've been pretty adamant.
You've tried to propose
to take away Donald Trump's
ability
to launch a first strike attack.
Don't you think now would be the
time to give him that option?
-Not at all.
-No?
We're getting this much closer
to doomsday.
Give that guy the keys
to the car.
So this is something
I think most people
will find interesting.
How do you launch a nuclear
weapon in America?
President wakes up one morning
and says,
"Hey. I'm angry; I want to go
nuke some country."
Secretary of defense has to
execute that order.
The order goes down through
military chain of command,
and missiles launch.
It is that easy.
Congress is not involved, the
judiciary is not involved.
There's no way the framers of
the Constitution
would have let a small amount of
people destroy the entire world
without additional checks
and balances.
Well, I think it's good that
it's easy for Donald Trump.
I mean, you make it too hard,
that guy's not gonna be able
to do anything with it.
So we're trying
to make it harder.
So my legislation with
Senator Ed Markey
is bipartisan, and says
before the president
can launch a
nuclear first strike,
he first has to get the approval
of Congress.
-Congress has to agree
on that. -Absolutely.
I think we're pretty safe
from nuclear war, then,
-if that's the case.
-That's the point of it.
Congressman Ted Lieu.